최민경 수의사님이었습니다.
왜 혼자 계속 유격을 하는 그..
머리 꺾어 강아지가..
병원, 강아지 병원.
근데 이거 진짜 사실인가요?
잠시만요, 저는 궁금한 게 있습니다.
제가 편책을 하다가..
궁금증.
종이 뭐죠, 이게?
얼터너티브라고 그러죠.
네, 요즘은.
안녕하세요.
비지르즈..
비지르초대서 코스트를 맡은 허키시바새끼
김간지입니다.
오늘은 특별히
허키..
하..
씨가 이제..
그렇죠.
호스트.
호스트를 맡았는데
운전을.
굉장히 그..
네.
힘드네요, 시작부터.
운전을 하기로 했는데
오늘 제가 그..
진행을 맡기로 했었는데
대사 없다고 찡찡거렸더니
아주 그냥 큰 일을 하는..
죄송합니다, 시작부터.
우리가..
여러분들이 항상
간지, 허키, 민경
그렇죠.
계속..
애걸복걸해서
저희가
또 다른 민경님을..
어떤 민경이죠, 오늘은?
오늘은 좀..
약한 민경인 것 같아요.
약한 민경..
일진 아니신 것 같고.
오늘..
저희와 함께 해주실
최민경 수의사님 모셨습니다.
그리고
저는 이제
깜딩이를
데려왔고요.
또 다른 호스트
훌륭이를 데려왔습니다.
네.
조금..
저는 지금 후회가 돼요.
조금 잘못 데려온 것 같다
라는 생각이..
가만 좀 있어.
어떻게 하면 좋을까요, 이런 상황이?
네.
하여튼 오늘 다시 한 번 소개를 좀 해보죠.
그러면 오늘 모신 민경님은?
제가.. 제가 할까요?
네, 네. 민경님 소개를 좀 부탁드릴게요.
네, 알겠습니다.
네, 안녕하세요. 저는
놀로동물행동클리닉이라는 곳에서
수의사를 근무하고 있는
최민경이라고 합니다.
반갑습니다.
민경님, 저희를 원래 좀 알고 계셨나요?
네.
저는..
어떤 일로?
그러니까 사실 저는 고등학교 때
그 술탄 오브 더 디스코랑
불..
아, 진짜요?
공연도 막 간 적이 있고요.
네. 그랬고
그리고 최근에 황깨님은
그 대표님의
두쫑크 먹방을..
아, 대표님?
네.
어, 굉장히 최신이네요.
되게 최신이다.
네, 맞아요.
혹시 그 술탄 오브 더 디스코에서 누가 제일
그 최애 멤버인가요?
강진님이요.
제가 뭐 사전에 알고 이렇게 섭외한 건 아니고요.
근데 어쨌든 올해로 어떻게 수의사를 몇 년이나 하셨나요?
저는 올해로 이제 5년 차가 됐어요.
5년 차?
그럼 왜 어쩌다가 수의사를 할 결심을 하신 거예요?
제가 초등학교 때 이제 첫 번째 반려견을 키웠는데
약간, 약간 어떻게 보면 진부한 얘기일 수도 있는데
그때 이제 강아지가 너무 좋아가지고
그래서 사실 저는 수능도 네 번 봤거든요.
진짜 수의사가 되고 싶어서.
근데 계속 뭐 실패하고 실패하고 실패하다가
아, 근데 진짜 수의사가 너무 되고 싶다.
그래서 저희 집 강아지 때문에 수의사가 됐어요.
오, 그럼 진짜 수의사가 되기 위해서 수능을 네 번 치르신 거예요?
네. 수의대 가고 싶어서.
오, 그거 가기가 어렵나요, 굉장히?
어, 그..
어렵겠지, 씨.
모르니까.
몰라.
생각보다 쉽지 않더라고요.
호키님은 혹시 수의사라는 직업에 대해서
네.
또 호키님이 편견?
편견?
그..
그 정치로 유명하잖아요.
지금.
뭐 여러 가지 갖고 있는데.
네, 인터넷에서 그렇게 떠들고 있던데.
혹시 갖고 있는 뭐 그런 거 있나요?
아, 장난 아니고 그냥 수의사에 제가 편견을 감히 가질 게 뭐가 있겠습니까?
그냥 수의사의 숫자가 어떤, 무슨 수예요?
그 금수, 맹수 할 때 숫자가?
응, 맞아요.
그 짐승들.
아, 그 짐승들.
네, 동물수라고.
그러면 모든 이 짐승들을 다 다루시는 건지 아니면 그 전문적인 그게 있는지?
다 다루는 거 아니에요?
사실 학교 다닐 때는.
소동물을 보통 개, 고양이 친구들을 소동물이라고 하고
대동물은 소, 돼지 이런 친구들이 있고요.
소동물이 소라고요?
소동물이 조그마한 소.
송아지?
아니요. 소동물, 대동물, 특수동물 이렇게 나눠져 있는데
무슨 소를 짜요?
소동물이 작은 소예요.
소라 작지 않잖아요.
그러니까 그 소는 작은 소.
그래서 대동물이 소, 돼지.
그 소는 카오고.
뭔 소리야?
이거는 작은 소 자.
소동물에는 개, 고양이가 있고요.
그리고 대동물에는 소, 돼지가 있고.
웃기려고 한 거 아니고 진짜 몰랐어요, 지금.
그리고 특수동물은 요즘에 뭐 새나, 거북이, 이구아나, 도마뱀 이런 친구들.
잠시 질문 궁금한 게 있습니다.
제가 산책을 하다가 새를 줏은 적이 있거든요.
일명 새줍이라고 하죠.
새를 줏었는데.
흔하진 않은데.
다쳤어요, 새가 다쳐가지고.
제가 이거 박스에 담아가지고 이 친구를 어떻게 해야 하나 고민을 했거든요.
제 케이스는 어떤 거였냐면, 전화를 했어요, 어디 무슨 조류.
그래서 전화했는데 이분이 술 취했었거든요.
술 취해 계신 거예요.
네.
그래갖고 계속 아, 그 새라는 건 말이죠, 이러면서.
아, 진짜요?
그거에 대해서 되게 한 시간 정도 설명하시더니.
그냥 뭐 원래 있던데 두시라고.
뭐 하여튼 대충 되게 무책임하게 끝났거든요.
아.
이럴 땐 어떻게 해야 하나요?
보통은 저희가 이제 권장드리는 방법은 이거 너무 약간 재미없는 대답일 수 있겠지만,
다산 콜센터에 전화하셔서
야생동물센터가 약간 권역별로 있어요.
뭐 서울, 경기, 강원도.
내가 정확히 그렇게 한 거 같은데.
저도 옛날에 학원에, 보습학원에 초등학생 때 새가 들어온 거예요, 참새가.
가끔 그럴 때 있잖아요.
네, 맞아요.
그래가지고 새가 잘 못 날더라고.
그래서 제가 다리에 실을 묶어가지고 집에 데려갔거든요.
흥부전 보고 하신 거 아니에요?
아니요.
뭔가 좀 나한테 뭐가 이익이 있을까.
아니요, 아니요.
눈 날리고 있을 때 나는 참새를 날리면 어떨까.
이거 동물학대 아닌가요, 이거는?
아니, 근데 이제 다 나았어요.
나아지고 한 3일쯤 지나서 나아가지고
아, 이제 우리가 정이 쌓였으니까 밖에서 날리면 다시 돌아오겠지라고 했는데.
그대로 나아졌죠.
사라졌어요.
그 친구 은혜를 아직 안 갚았네요, 그러면.
안 갚았죠.
빚을 졌네요.
역시 짐승들은.
짐승들은.
근데 지금 동물행동클리닉에서 일하신다고 그러는데.
네.
이 동물병원이랑 좀 다른 거죠?
네, 맞아요.
그러니까 일반적인 정말 기본 진료까지는 저희가 보는데 사람으로 치면 약간 동물정신과의 느낌이에요.
그러면 지금 대충 딱 봐도 강아지가 정신 상태가 어떻다 이런 게 보이나요?
그렇죠.
근데 이 친구는 지금 정신 상태가 어떤 거 같아요?
아니, 이 친구는.
최고의 강아지예요.
최고의 견.
네.
올해 최고의 강아지.
딱 봤을 때 첫인상은 최고다.
네.
그래서.
지금.
여기 없는 친구는 지금.
근데 지금.
어디 가 계신데요?
지금 다른 데 가 계시거든요.
아니, 이 친구 뭡니까, 도대체.
저는 이런 걸 처음 봤어요.
아, 정말요?
잠시 다른 데로 가 계시는데 저 친구는 지금 정신 상태가 어떤 거 같습니까?
근데 저 친구도 성격이 되게 좋은 편인 거예요.
좋죠.
네.
어떻게 보면 진짜 약간 해맑고 그러니까 이 친구는 되게 진중한 성격인 것 같고.
훌륭히는 되게 호기심도 많고 자기가 직접 봐야 되고 에너지도 좀 있는 편인 것 같고.
집에 있을 때는 참 좋은데.
아.
이렇게 데리고 나오니까 너무 힘드네요.
훌륭히가 지금 7살이죠?
7살입니다.
네.
아무튼 수의사님들은 어떤 직업병 같은 게 있을까요?
딱 봤을 때.
아, 직업병은.
이제 길 가면은 저 이렇게 뒤뚱뒤뚱 걷는 친구 보면 아주 거관점이 좋은 것 같아.
아, 저 지금 슬개골 탈고.
네.
슬개골 탈고 있을 것 같아요.
몇 개월째 하는 거.
아, 뭔가 십자인데 막 걱정되는데.
고도비만이다 이런 거.
네.
현장에서 오지랖 같은 거 좀 부르고.
이렇게 좀.
아.
그거 안 돼.
이런 식으로 해 본 적 있으십니까, 혹시?
아니, 왜 걔한테 그래요.
왜 그래요, 당신은 이런 식으로.
오히려 그걸 반대로 당해 본 적이 있어요.
아, 정말요?
네.
감히? 수의사한테.
근데 예를 들면 저는 제 방식대로 이제 맞는 방법을 쓰는데.
옆에서 하시는 분이 오셔가지고.
에이, 그렇게 하면 안 된다.
혼내야 된다.
막 이러면.
때려야 된다.
막 이렇게 하시는 분이 계셔가지고.
약간 이런 생각을 할 때도.
열 받는 포인트.
네.
라이센스 딱 보여주면서 이제.
맨날 수의사한테 그러거든요.
아유.
뭐 되냐.
어.
무슨 뭐 됩니까?
너 알아.
나 최민경이야, 인마.
아무튼 저희가 수의사라는 직업에 대해서 조금 알아봤는데.
저희가 조금 오늘 중요한 날입니다.
왜죠?
각자.
이제 나이를 많이 먹었잖아요.
저랑 화키 님이랑요.
그렇죠.
일을 언제까지 할 수도 없고.
얘네들도 돈을 벌어야 되거든요.
오늘 데뷔를 시켜서.
그러니까 인스타 파야죠.
하나 만들어야죠.
저.
사실 원래.
아.
있어?
훌륭히.
준비를 하고 있었네.
이미 있는데.
약간 했고.
아직은.
그래서 저희가 또 수의사님을 또 개인적으로.
궁금한 것도 또 물어보고.
그러기 위해서.
나의 반려견 자랑 대회.
누구부터 할까요?
먼저 시작하시죠.
저부터요?
아니.
제가 먼저 할까요?
네.
알겠습니다.
왜죠?
장유유서라고.
어린 새끼.
동생 먼저?
네.
알겠습니다.
자. 훌륭이.
이름.
훌륭이는.
그.
개는 훌륭하다.
를 보고 지었.
인 줄 아는 사람들이 좀 있는데.
아.
제가 먼저입니다.
제가 먼저.
훌륭하게 잘하라.
훌륭하게 잘해라.
훌륭이는.
어떤 특징이 있나요?
어.
특징이.
지금도 보면 아시겠지만.
활발해요.
활발하고.
겁이 없는 것 같아요?
겁은 좀.
아예 없어요.
그렇죠.
낯도 좀 안 가리고.
외향.
어.
외향일 순 있는데.
사교적이지는 않은 것 같아요.
맞아요.
그럴 것 같아요.
네.
눈치를 잘 안 보는 느낌?
외향과 내용이 딱.
반.
경계선에 있는 것 같아요.
음.
그러니까 사람을 엄청 좋아하지는 않거든요.
근데 호기심은 있어요.
음.
근데 또 사람 손이 이렇게 다가가면 좀 피해요.
맞아요.
음.
저의.
강아지 이름은.
깜딩.
깜딩이입니다.
깜딩이.
왜 깜딩이냐.
까매서요.
하지만.
그렇게 이름을 짓는 게.
피씨하지 못하다는 걸 깨달았었어요.
조금 약간 인종섭요를.
네.
인종적인 그런.
혹시 영어 이름 있나요?
영어 이름?
네.
아직 안 지었나요?
아직 안 지었는데.
음.
마이클 조던?
너무 어릴 때 지은 거고.
음.
우리 그때는 강아지 이름을 개똥이.
어.
개똥.
예.
이상한 이름으로 지어야지.
오래 산다고.
오래 산다는 그런 좀 미신이 있었습니다.
그래서 아무 생각 없이 깜딩이라고 지었고.
나이는 추정이에요.
14살.
왜냐.
주웠습니다.
길에서.
음.
길에서 주워가지고.
멍죽?
네.
멍죽.
간택 받았다고 그러죠.
네.
갑자기 이제 추운 겨울날 제 품으로 후닥하고 달려온 거예요.
어디였죠?
어디요?
부천.
부천에서.
네.
집에 가는 길.
너무 추운 날인데 이제 패딩에 넣고 그 가게에 가가지고.
혹시 이 개 본 적 있냐.
그건 3일 전부터 계속 돌아다녔대요.
그래서 버렸구나.
그래서 이제 집에 데려와서 그때 이제 나이를 1살로 추정했을 때.
지금은 이제 한 10.
4.
15살.
정도 되지 않았나.
그러면 이제 깜딩이만의 어떤 특징이 있다면?
너무 얌전합니다.
그런 거 같아요.
네.
우울한 거 아니죠 지금?
슬픈 거 아니죠?
우울한 거 아니에요.
오히려 굉장히 편해 보이고.
아 그래요?
네.
근데 왜 그러냐면은 그 깜딩이 키우기 전에 또 땅콩이라고.
욕구셔가 한 마리 있었어요.
그건 이제 또 어머니가 어디서 핍박 받는 강아지를 하나 주워왔는데.
이제 너무 핍박을 받다가 이제 우리 집에서 슬금슬금.
가족 구성원이 돼가는 도중에 갑자기 얘가 온 거예요.
내가 데리고 온 거야.
그래서 저 처음에 얘를 키울 생각이 없었거든요.
왜냐면 그 친구한테는 너무 미안하잖아요.
그래가지고 입양하실 분 해가지고 이제 SNS에 막 올렸는데 하루 자고 일어나 보니까 안 되겠더라고요.
그죠.
왜냐면 그때 잘 때 욕구셔는 무조건 제 겨드랑이에서 자고 이 친구 이제 눈치 보기 시작하면서 슬금슬금.
제 다리 사이에 이제.
딱 그 자리를 잡는데.
욕구셔가 먼저고 그다음이 이 친구였거든요.
그렇게 하다 보니까 친구가 눈치를 좀 많이 봤었어요.
그때는 너무 눈치를 많이 보고.
그랬는데 요즘에는 나이를 먹고 이제 해탈한 것 같아요.
뭔가 별 신경 안 쓰고 몰라.
뭐 약간 이런 느낌.
그만큼 이 친구는 너무 얌전하다.
이 특징입니다.
이렇게 얌전한 친구는 없어요.
눈치를 보지는 않았을 거예요.
그리고 그냥 이 친구의 타고난 그냥 되게 좋은 성향이었던 것 같고.
왜냐면 보통 저희가 다견 가정 키우시는 분들이 첫째가 원래 집에 있고 둘째를 이렇게 데리고 왔을 때 싸우는 경우는 둘째가 첫째를 이기려고 할 때예요.
그러면 얘네끼리 서열 싸움을 계속해요.
이게 평생을 안 잡히는 친구들도 있거든요.
근데 아마 둘이 싸운 적 없죠.
없어요.
그쵸.
그러니까 아마 깜딩이가 자기가 난 이제 둘째네.
그러면 항상.
그리고 땅콩이.
먼저 챙겨주시고 깜딩이 챙겨주셨으니까 이게 정말 관리도 잘해주신 거고요.
원래 그게 맞는 거예요.
항상 첫째를 먼저 챙겨주시고 둘째를 챙겨주셔야 깜딩이도 그 친구 눈치를 안 보고 그리고 땅콩이도 스트레스를 안 받아요.
깜딩이 때문에.
그래서 어떻게 보면 진짜로 최고로 잘해주신 것 같아요.
들으셨죠?
네.
저 진짜 어떻게 보면 정말 정석적으로 잘해주신 보호자님이신 것 같아요.
궁금증.
종이 뭐죠 이게?
얼터너티브라고 그러죠.
네. 요즘.
너무 시골도 아니고.
얼터너티브.
각자 좀 강아지 자랑을 좀 해본다면은.
일단은 저 키우는 난이도가 매우 낮습니다.
아주 별로 할 게 없고.
뭐 이렇게 요구 같은 거 안 하나요?
없어요.
그냥 밥 주니까 저렇게 됐어요.
그냥.
뭐 한 게 없어요.
별로.
밥 주고 그냥 뭐 치워주고 산책해 주고 그냥 난이도가 거의 없고 짖질 않습니다.
음.
아 목소리가 없는 게 아니고 아주 레어하게 한 번 어쩌다 짖고.
어쩔 때 짖어요?
어쩔 때 짖냐면은 아파트니까 아내가 이제 차 타고 들어올 때.
아 주차.
그러면 주차 벨 소리가 나잖아요.
그럼 얘가 누워있다가 땡 소리 나면은 한 번 막 이 정도가 맥스.
그 이후로는 제가 한 이 콤보까지는 본 적이 있거든요.
막 막 이거.
그게 제가 본 최고의 짖음이었어요.
와 근데 진짜 최고의 강아지인 게.
네.
그러니까 그 막 막 이거는 그거예요.
어 왔다.
네.
그냥 그거예요.
아 그래요?
사람을 놓치면은 그냥 어 아마 이제 알 거예요.
그 주차 벨이 딱 울리면 보호자님이 들어오신다는 걸 알아서 어 왔다.
이렇게 한 번 딱 알리고 끝이에요.
맞아요.
네.
막 막 하고 한 번 내 쪽을 봐요.
음.
아.
그럼 뭐 어쩌라고 어떻게 알아요.
들어보면 이제 좀 반가워하고 그런 정도?
그러니까 불만족스러운 것도 없는 것 같고요.
어 있을 수가 없죠.
네.
감히.
이렇게 먹을 거를 다 챙겨주고 재워주고 다 해주는데 불만이 있으면 안 되죠.
왜 혼자 계속 유격을 하는 그.
좀 관심 받고 싶어서.
브레이크 댄스를.
연습을 하고 있는.
즐겨 합니다.
끼 발산.
뭐 저는 그 정도.
그 어떤 자랑할 거리는.
깜딩이는 어.
일단 저는 외모가.
너무 귀여워요.
네.
외모가 일단 좀.
미쳤어요.
네.
진짜.
저 생김새가.
이게.
안 좋아할 수가 없네요.
맞나요 여러분?
실화냐?
진짜.
이렇게 안아가지고.
대충.
여기 좀 이렇게 숨기잖아요.
아무도.
걔랑 같이 있는지 몰라요.
시꺼매서 그런가.
아니 그.
너무.
조용하고.
혹시 화를 내는 걸 본 적 있습니까?
화냅니다.
화내요?
네.
어.
어떻게.
제가 괴롭히면.
오.
그래서 제가.
고백을 좀 하자면.
저도 그 모습이 한 번 보고 싶어서.
신기를 계속 건드려봤거든요.
얘가 이제 화내는 꼴을 한 번 보고 싶은 거예요.
내가.
그래서 끝까지 한 번 이렇게.
야야.
이러면서 엄청 괴롭혀 봤거든요.
절대 화를 안 냅니다.
진짜 최고야 강아지.
그거 본 적이 없어요.
어떻게 해야지 화를 열 열 열 열 받게 할 수 있을까.
엄청 이렇게 막.
계속 귀에다 바람 넣고 막 이렇게 한 번 해봤거든요.
네.
그럼 어때요?
그냥 피하기만 해요?
그냥 하지 마.
약간 이런 느낌?
아.
끝까지 화를 안 내요.
되게 화가 없는.
어떻게 보면 사람으로 치면 약간 머리 꽃밭 강아지가.
대가리가 꽃밭.
저 친구 자기 똥도 먹죠?
잘 먹습니다.
저의 첫 만남이 똥을 먹고 있는 모습이었어요.
자급자족이라고.
근데 둘 다 너무 최고의 강아지예요.
진짜 성격적으로.
다른 물론 성향은 둘이 다르지만.
저는 이렇게 문제 행동을 가지고 있는 아이들이 많이 오거든요.
근데 그 딱 보현이 오시면 다른 집 강아지는 안 그러는데 왜 우리 집 강아지만 그래요라고 하시는 다른 집 강아지를 담당하고 있는 것 같아요.
제 생각에는.
그게 이 강아지가 주인을 닮아서 일까요?
근데 보호자 성향을.
근데 보호자 성향 진짜 닮아요.
진짜요?
네.
근데 저는 이런 성향이 아닌데.
이건 정신 이상한 건데.
아니에요.
아니요.
근데 진짜로 텐션이 높은.
강아지도 ADHD가 있거든요.
아니요.
진짜 ADHD 강아지를 못 보셔서 그래요.
이 정도면 진짜 양호해서.
만약에 허기님께서 저희 병원에 오셔서 이 문제 행동 있는 것 같아요 하면 저희는 그냥 돌려보냈을 것 같아요.
문제 없죠.
네.
진짜 문제 없고.
그다음에 이런 것도 그냥 지금 사실 여기 카메라도 너무 많고 조명도 있잖아요.
그러니까 어떻게 보면 약간.
입장에서 여기 좀 낯선 공간인데 해서 자꾸 이렇게 핥으면 안정감을 느끼거든요.
저를 주인을 닮아서 이런다는 말에는 좀 동의하기가 힘드네요.
그 어떤 강아지가 주인을 저는 좀 닮는다고 생각합니다.
맞아요.
왜냐하면 저는 집에서 소리를 아예 거의 안 내고 이 집안 분위기가 고요해야 된다.
그래서 깜딩이도 똑같이 고요한 거죠.
깜딩이 갑자기 웡 하고 짖으면 시선이 쏠리게 돼요.
뭔데?
큰일이어야 될 것이야.
감히 소리를 내?
누가 소리를 내었는가?
누군가?
그리고 생각보다 얼굴도 닮는데요.
아이고 무슨 말을 그렇게 하세요.
저 강아지는 이상합니다.
유니크하다고 해주세요.
직관적으로 이상해요.
이것 좀 보세요.
깜딩이 진짜 착하죠.
그렇죠.
저런 걸 받아주잖아요.
인정하는 거는 애가 조금 사교적이지 못하긴 해요. 저렇게 좀.
원래 같으면 코를 물어 뜯어야 되거든요.
보통 이렇게 으르렁 한번 하거나 으르렁 해야 되는데 다 받아주네요.
얘는 저런 걸 보면 웬만하면 궁금증을 한번 제가 얘기를 해볼게요.
보통 저러면 혼나기도 하고 다른 개들이 싫어하는 거를 많이 보고 살았을 거 아니에요.
그럼 저 안 그래야 되는데
계속 저 이런 짓을 하거든요.
그러니까 누굴 봐도 눈치 안 보고 그냥 계속 와 반갑다 이거를 해요.
고쳐질까요? 아니면 계속 이렇게 될까요?
이거 아마 계속 그럴 거예요.
근데 이거를 저희는 좀 어떻게 보면 되게 좋은 성형이라고 하는 게 회복 탄력성이 되게 높은 거거든요.
그러니까 상처가 없어요.
그래서 이런 친구들은 진짜 한번 큰 친구들한테 호되게 혼나면 조금 줄어들기도 하고요.
친구한테 사지를 다 뜯기면.
그래서 눈 안쪽이.
시간이 해결해 주는 문제긴 해요.
그러니까 10살 넘어가고 15살 넘어가면 철드는 저희 구간이 있거든요.
이렇게 철드는 게 아니라 이렇게 뚝뚝 철이 들어요.
제가 또 궁금한 거는 혹시 강아지들도 좀 이런 게 있나요?
외모 차별을 좀 하나요?
왜냐하면 제가 이건 정말 궁금한 건데 훌륭이를 데리고 나가면 대부분 싫어하거든요.
다른 개들이.
대부분 싫어해요.
생긴 것만 보고.
생긴 것만 보고 그러진 않겠죠.
전체적인.
아니 근데 맞아요.
제가 볼 때는 이거는 분명한 차별이다.
티드키는 잘 놀거든요.
근데 얘는 보는 순간 일단 싫어하는 티가 확 나요.
다른 쪽 개가.
저 너무 싫다.
생긴 개 너무 싫다.
이런 느낌이에요.
그래서 제가 프렌치 불독들 다니는 놀이터가 따로 있거든요.
카페.
거기 가면 또 환영받아요.
그렇죠.
거기 가면 이제 잘 만났다 하면서 신나게 놀아요.
외모 차별이 좀 많나요 지금?
네.
그래서 저희가 예를 들면 퍼피 클래스 같은 거 진행을 할 때 그 기수에.
못생긴 반 따로 있고.
아니요.
오히려 섞어놔요.
그러니까 왜 그러냐면 우리나라는 말티즈, 푸들, 비숑이 제일 많아요.
그러면 이 강아지들도 지나가면서 익숙한 얼굴들이 푸들, 비숑, 말티즈.
이런 친구들이에요.
그런데 그러다가 어쩌다가 이런 단두종 친구들.
눈 엄청 크고 코 이렇게 찌부되어 있는 친구들 보면 이 입장에서는
되게 외계인 보는 느낌인 거예요.
지금까지 내가 보지 못한 얼굴이잖아요.
엄청나게 경계를.
맞아요.
게다가 이런 친구들 특징이 코가 약간 좀 짧고 이러니까 또 숨소리도
좀 거칠어요.
그렇죠.
이렇게 막 이러니까.
눈 이만하죠?
코 짧죠?
그런데 막 숨소리 거칠죠?
그리고 또 이런 친구들이 막 이렇게 성격도 되게 좋으니까.
마냥 막 이만하잖아요.
그렇죠.
그러니까 마냥 막 신나서 막 들이대요.
그만해.
그러니까 얘네들은 기겁을 하는 거예요.
어쩔 수 없이 비슷한 애들끼리 놀게 하는.
네.
그래서 이게 단두종의 되게 슬픈 약간 슬픈 사연이에요.
그리고 그 브레이크 댄스는 제가 아까도 계속 보셨지만 댄스를 엄청
제가 어디 새로운 데 갈 때마다 저러거든요.
산책만 나가면 어딜 가든 어떤 스팟에서 저 행동을 하거든요.
그럼 왜 그러는 거예요?
그래서 제가 그 스스로를 잘 모르는 게 아니라 제가 그 스스로를 잘 모르는
거에요.
아.
네.
그 냄새를 남김으로써 이룰 수 있는 게 뭐가 있어서 그러는 거죠?
저 친구는?
나 여기.
그러니까 목적이 뭐예요 그게?
외로운 거죠.
슬픈 건가?
네.
나 여기 있어.
비숑과 이 푸들과 그 무리에.
차별을 너무 당해서 그런 거.
안겨주는 거를 냄새로라도 알리고 싶은 거.
네.
그래서 저희는 그냥 sns라고 말씀드려요.
나 여기 왔음.
네.
이렇게 왔음.
인스타 중독자네.
중독자.
어떻게 하면.
독파는 중독자네.
그냥.
왜냐하면 깜딩이도 1년에 한두 번 정도 합니다.
그 이제 뒹구는 거잖아요.
저는 그거를 좀 자주 보고 싶은데 이 할 때 전조가 있어요.
킁킁킁킁킁킁킁 돌아다니다가 누울지 말지 고민하다가 삐리리 하고
한 번 구른단 말이에요.
그러니까 그거는 이제 깜딩이 같은 친구는 인스타 포스팅할 때 좀 고민
하는.
아.
약간 힙스터 느낌으로.
올려야.
이거 멋있나?
아이 몰라 이러면서 흥 누르는 그런 느낌.
여기 감도 많나?
지금.
이렇게 올린 거랑 이렇게 해가지고 흑백톤 맞나?
메모장에 한 번 코멘트 써보고.
좀 내면은 좀 알아봤지만 훌륭이야 깜딩이가 좀 수의사님이 보시기에는
건강해 보이나요?
깜딩이는.
근데 사실 이거는 나이 때문에 그럴 수 있긴 한데 다이어트가 조금 필요한
것 같기는 해요.
아.
생각도 못 했단 말이네.
이 토실토실한 빵댕이가 다이어트가 좀 필요하다.
네.
그래서 사실은 저희도 애들이 이렇게 막 찌면 찔수록 귀엽잖아요.
그래서 저희도 항상 아 살을 좀 빼야 될 것 같아요 라고 말씀드리면
보호자님이 약간 부정을 하시는 경우가 있어요.
그럴 리 없어.
그럴 리 없어요.
이거 얼마나 귀여운데 라고 하지만 이제 정말 딱 수의사적인 그걸로
만 봤을 때는 아이들이 살이 찌면 조금의 과체중이 수명을 한 3년씩
깎아먹거든요.
그래서 저는 오르막길 위주로 조금 산책해 주시는 것도 좋을 것 같아요
.
10분 정도는 막 동산 같은 이제 너무 등산은 안 하셔도 되고 약간
좀 경사 있는 곳에 10분 정도.
이 배가 진짜 부드럽거든요.
하 진짜 마법의 배여가지고 자 마법의 배 좀 한 번 보자.
근데 사실 실제로 그 연구 결과가 있는 게 사람이 강아지를 쓰다듬을
때는 사람의 코리티 수치가 내려가 거든요.
네.
근데 강아지는 올라간대요.
아.
.
네.
근데 뭐 또 뭐 강아지랑 이렇게 마주 보면 뭐냐 옥시토신 뭐 하고
.
맞아요.
좋아진다면서요.
네.
그래서 그 사람이랑 눈을 마주쳤 을 때 옥시토신 호르몬이 사랑 호르몬
이거든요.
네.
그 나오는 유일한 동물이 강아지 래요.
음.
고양이는 안 나와요.
네.
걔네는 나오는데 생기지도 않았어요 .
그러긴 해.
그래서 서로 강아지도 사람 눈을 쳐다볼 때 옥시토신 나오고 사람도
강아지를 쳐다볼 때 옥시토신 나와요.
서로 나와요.
음.
좋네요.
네.
훌륭이는 일단 근육이 진짜 탁월한 것 같아요.
뇌도 근육일 것 같아요.
네.
간단할 것 같아요.
.
그리고 이제 지금은 사실 그렇게 크게 문제가 없어 보이긴 하는데
이제 아무래도 눈이 약간 튀어나와 있잖아요.
그래서 이 친구들의 고질적인 문제가 이제 나중에 안압이 높아진다거나
아니면 안구건조증이 좀 심한다 거나 눈에 만성적으로 염증이 생기는
경우가 많아서 뭐 인공눈물 자주 넣어주신다거나 아니면 주기적으로
안압검사 같은 거 해 주시는 게 좋아요 .
알겠습니다.
그것도 있잖아요.
그 체리아이.
눈 빠지는 친구들도 있더라고요.
네.
맞아요.
제 깜디기가 좀 그렇거든요.
아.
이 친구는 좀 눈이 나와 있는.
한쪽만 이렇게 좀 빠질 때 있어서 그 마사지를 유튜브 보고 배워
가지고.
음.
그리고 깜디기 같은 경우에도 약간 눈이 뿌옇게 되고 있어요.
네.
그래서 이것도 주기적으로 조금 검사해 주시면 좋을 것 같아요.
아이들이 눈이 하얘지는 게 무조건 백내장은 아니고 핵경화증이라는
걸 수도 있거든요.
그런데 핵경화증은 시력에 영향을 안 주고 백내장은 시력에 영향을
주니까 이게 초기에는 구별을 하려면 정말 정확한 정리 검사가 필요
해요.
그래서 해 주시고 그거에 맞게 관리해 주시면 좋을 것 같아요.
저기 훌륭히 같은 경우에 눈이랑 피부가 아주 그냥 평소에 안 좋아요
.
아.
알러지.
알러지가 많고.
오.
고기류 같은 걸 좀 잘 안 먹고.
아.
그래서 지금 간식도 이렇게.
먹으면 이렇게 뭐가 나요.
이렇게 빨개져요.
음.
네.
그래서 이런 친구들은 약간.
오메가3 같은 거 챙겨주시면.
맨날 챙기고 있습니다.
오메가3를.
오.
관리 진짜 잘해주고 계시는데.
하여튼 제가 좀 궁금했던 거는 동물 의료 기술이 옛날에 비해 얼마
큼 발전했을까.
그러니까 혹시 그리고 그 발전이 이런 강아지들 애완견 애완동물들의
수명에도 영향을 미치는가.
저도 이렇게 빨리 발전할 줄은 몰랐어요.
그러니까 제가 입학할 때만 해도 이게 언제쯤 발전이 될까.
그러니까 저도 뭔가.
이런 거에 대해서 좀 더 공부하고 싶다 해도 자료도 많이 없고.
그래서 만약에 이 친구가 이런 병이 있어도 더 이상 해줄 게 없었을 때가
있었거든요.
그런데 요즘에는 진짜 전문 병원도 너무 많이 생겼고요.
그러니까 예를 들면 정형외과 그다음에 치과 안과 그다음에 이제는 뭐
요즘 소화기 내과도 따로 분과로 생겼고 피부과도 생겼고.
그래서 예전에는 반려견들이 암에 걸렸으면 기세수명이 진짜 짧아졌는데
요즘에는 초기에 발견하고 사람처럼 똑같이 항암 치료를 하면은.
이게 수명이 확실히 늘어나는 경우도 있고.
요즘 20살도 애들이 날라다니거든요.
그리고 15살 지금 깜낑이도 그렇지만 전혀 그렇게 막 괜찮잖아요.
저는 확실히 체감을 하는 게 그 어릴 때 키웠던 강아지랑 지금 비교해 보면은 확실히 좀 달라졌어요.
그렇죠.
그리고 저는 이제 어릴 때 대문을 그냥 열어놓고 강아지가 밖에 나갔다가.
맞아.
한 저녁 9시쯤 되면은 집에 들어와요.
그래서 문 열어달라고 긁어요.
문을 열어주면은 잤다가 아침에 또 쏠랑 나갔다가.
그러니까 이거 밖에서.
직장인이네요.
네.
그래서 제가 이제 초등학교 등교를 하는데 들개 한 6마리가 막 떼지어서 몰려다니는데 그 중에 저희 강아지가 있는 거예요.
멤버로.
크루 가입했네요.
근데 저희 강아지가 암컷이어가지고 임신을 해서 온 거예요.
네.
그래서.
아빠는 누군지 모르고.
모르죠.
유추할 수밖에 없어요.
저 중에 한 명인데.
네.
근데 걔네들도 너무 웃긴 게 들갱이인 줄 알았는데.
혹시.
우리 동네 사내네.
그러니까 열리면은 갔다가 밤에 우리 집처럼 다 똑같이 들어간다.
그때는 수명이 좀 짧았습니다.
그때는.
수명도 짧았고 그때는 그런 식으로 이제 출퇴근하면서 강아지들이 사라지는 경우가 되게 많았어요.
그렇죠.
그런 적도 많고.
그래서 저는 확실히 그 의료 기술이라는 게 동물 의료 기술이 보편적으로도 굉장히 좀 발전했다고 느끼는데 이 병원 강아지 병원 어렵습니다.
어떤 부분이에요.
안 가고 싶어요. 되도록이면.
한 번 갔다 오면은.
뭐 어떤 경험이 있으신가요.
저는.
안 좋게 되는.
자주 가죠.
체리아이 처음 발견했을 때.
이 체리아이라는 게 속 눈꺼풀을 지탱해주는 이 근육이 좀 약해지면서.
맞아요.
속 눈꺼풀이 좀 튀어나오는 거예요.
깜짝 놀란 거예요.
이거 무슨 눈에 무슨 큰일 난 거 아닌가.
바로 동물병원을 데려갔는데 5만 원을 받았습니다.
의사 선생님이.
네.
그거 치료가 됐어요.
안약이랑.
나중에 알고 봤더니.
이 마사지를 하면은 이게 또 들어가는 거잖아요.
이게 제가 개인적으로 마사지를 하면.
분명히 그 동물병원 의사 선생님도 마사지를 했으니까.
네.
그래서.
그런데 회사 선생님도 마사지를 했을 텐데 이 진료비와 약값이 보험이
안되다 보니까 너무 비싼 거예요.
저는 보험 들었습니다.
뭐요.
강아지 보험
강아지 보험 들었습니다.
진짜
그 계기가 있어요.
얘가 이제.
가봐.
좀 좀 자.
aney 가서 앉어.
어.
그러니까.
계기가 무슨 옛날에 잠깐 그 뭐였죠 그 생식 같은 거 한다고.
causs로 사.
음.
먹이다가 그 제품 중에 하나가 이렇게 연골 그런게 하나가 좀 덩어리지가 큰게 있었던 거에요 그게 이제
요거 뭐라 그러죠 식도? 거기 끝에서 안 넘어간 거에요 그래서 계속 켁켁거려 가지고 그때 한번 병원 갔다가
어 아 진짜 죽느니 사느니 하는 안 좋은 경험을 한번 하고 그때 정말 무서웠거든요 저는
의사선생님이 일단 겁을 좀 많이 주세요 어쩔 수 없이 이제 그 경고하는 차원에서 이제 말씀을 많이 해주시는데
위험하다 뭐 어떻게 될지 모른다 이런 말을 들으니까 무서워 죽겠는 거에요 그 순간이 견디지 못하겠는 거에요
근데 다행히 안전하게 이제 수술을 하고 치료는 이건 다 꺼냈는데 나아졌는데 돈이 장난이 아니더라구요
4,500만원 나왔나요? 엄청 비싸더라구요
네
상상을 초월하게
그러니까 이게 이 우리 같은 사람들한테는 선택권이 없어요 뭐냐면은
돈을 내라면 낼꺼에요 그냥
너 지갑에 있는거 지금 다 내놔
아프면
네 이럴꺼에요
뭐 아프면 일단은 치료 받고
어쩔 수가 없어요 그냥
어 그리고 자 니가 갖고 있는 거 다 줘가 되거든요
여기 있어요
네 아니 아니 이게 어쩔 수가 없네 이렇게 돼 버리는 거에요
보이는게 그거밖에 없어요 그 사람은
그래서 당연히 이게 사람이 볼일을 보고나서
보고난 뒤에 마음이 다르다 할지언정 그만큼 동물병원을 더 멀리 하게 되는거죠 너무 무섭고 너무 비싸고 이게 맞는겁니까?
지금 이나라 이게 맞습니까?
사실 저도 수의사로 살면서this 얘기를 들을때마다 죄인이 되는 기분이기는 한데 이게 되게 구조상 어쩔 수가 없어요
그니까 예를 들면 그 사람 병원이랑 일단 동물병원의 차이는 사람은 예를 들면 뭐 채우를 할 때도 가만히 계세요 이러면 그냥 가능한건 아닌가요?
그걸 꽉 참고 가만히 있을 수 있어요.
그런데 강아지는 기본 두 명이 붙어서 보정을 해야 돼요.
그러니까 아무래도 거기에 인건비가 붙죠.
그리고 약 처방을 할 때는 사람은 어떤 건강보험도 기본적으로 되어 있지만
저희는 약국에서 약을 사서 받아요.
그러니까 어떻게 보면 의료보험이 적용이 안 된 그 가격을 받아요.
그러니까 약이 애초에 비싸게 들어가요.
약사를 통해서만 저희가 약을 받을 수가 있어서
그러니까 또 저희가 처방받는 약에 비해서 더 비싸게 들어오는 것도 두 번째고
또 기계값도 있고 이것저것 하다 보니까
생각보다 저희는 사람 병원에 비해서 남는 건 별로 없거든요.
쓰는 돈이 많구나.
네, 나가는 돈이 기본적으로 너무 많아요.
그런데 어쨌든 인터넷상에서 저희가 동물병원을 꼭 가기 전에
모든 것들은 다 인터넷에 검색을 해보잖아요.
사실은 일단 유튜브를 보죠.
그렇죠. 유튜브도 보고 요즘은 채티, PT한테 물어보기도 하고
강아지와 관련된 수많은 정보들이 있습니다.
강아지가 당신을 정말 주인으로 생각하는 이유 이러면
이제 하루 종일 그런 것만 띵띵띵이라면서
옆에서 잔다 이런 뻔한 얘기들 있잖아요.
어느 정도 걸러들 필요가 있을까요?
아니면 그런 걸 걸러들 수 있는 기준 같은 게 있을까요?
그래서 저는 어느 정도 걸러야 되는 게 있긴 해요.
제가 봤을 때 이건 말도 안 되는데? 라고 생각하는 것들이 좀 있거든요.
예를 들 수 있나요?
소개의 정도. 이건 개수작이다. 사기꾼. 미친놈. 쓰레기새끼. 그 정도까지 가려면 막 개는 때려야 된다.
아 그런 놈은 없잖아. 그 정도까지는 안 하잖아. 그런 사람이 있어요. 그런 사람이 있어요? 네. 유명한 짤이 있습니다.
일본에서 시바견 교육시킬 때. 한국일 거에요. 맞죠. 이렇게 해가지고 막 이렇게 진짜 근데 진짜 정신 차리더라고요.
그러니까 사람들이 그거를 바뀐 모습을 보고 효과라고 생각하고 그걸 갖고 오시고 아니면 그 방법을 쓰셔서 오시는 분들이 좀 있어요.
그래서 저는 그런 게 정말 극단적인 예시고 이런 거 있어요. 분리불화는 예뻐해서 생긴다.
그래서 안아주지 마세요. 오면 무시하세요. 나갔다 들어오면 모른 척하세요. 이런 게 다 틀린 말인데 생각보다 그거를 그대로 믿고 오시는 분들도 계세요.
사실 여기서 꼭 말씀드리고 싶은 게
그 이건 되게
흔하게 모든 분들이 알고 계시는 잘못 알고 계신 오해인데 강아지는 절대 사람보다 서열이 높다고 생각하지 않아요.
네. 그러니까 강아지들끼리는 서열이 완벽하게 잡혀야 평화를 찾을 수 있는데 얘네는 절대 사람보다 자기가 높다고 생각을 안 하거든요.
웬만하면 그러겠죠. 그렇죠. 근데 그 이유가 뭐냐면 강아지들 사이에서 서열 판단 기준은 내가 먼저 밥을 먹어야 돼요.
그래서 아까 전에 그 첫째 강아지 먼저 밥 챙겨주시고 이제 깜댕이 챙겨주셨다고 하셨잖아요. 그게 얘네들의 서열 판단 기준이어서
예를 들면 뭐 다섯 마리 키우는 집에서 서열이 제일 높은 친구가 먼저 밥을 못 먹잖아요. 그럼 다른 친구들이 다 눈치 보면서 안 먹고 기다리고 있어요.
그러니까 그게 서열인데 사실 사람이랑 강아지 사이에서는 얘네가 막 우리가 밥 먹는다고 해서 뭐라고 하진 않잖아요.
그러니까 그것처럼 얘네는 확실히 구별을 하고 있어요. 그러니까 고양이들은 사실은 같은 고양이라 생각한대요.
같이 살고 있는. 그래서 강아지가 좀 고양이랑 다른 점은 그냥 거대한 고양이네라고 생각을 하는데 강아지는 사람과
그 강아지, 나는 개고 사람은 사람이다 라고 완벽하게 구별을 하거든요.
근데 이제 사람들이 생각하는 얘가 그럼 나를 보고 막 짖고 내 쫓으려고 하는데 그럼 이거는 뭐예요 라고 생각을 하시는데 이거는 그냥 싫은 감정이에요.
그러니까 낯설어서 싫은 감정. 싫어서.
싫어! 이러고 있는 거잖아. 싫어! 가까이 오지 마세요. 약간 이러면서 짖는 거고.
그리고 그런 것도 있어요. 꼬리를 세우고 흔들고 있으면 무조건 좋은 기분이다. 이것도 약간의 오해예요.
그 강아지의 그 약간 행동을 생각을 할 때 가장 먼저 봐야 되는 건 앞뒤 상황 맥락이거든요.
맞아요. 그런 거 같아요.
오히려 너무 경계해도 아이들이 꼬리가 이렇게 수직으로 서 있는 경우도 있어요.
근데 그걸 모르고 얘가 나 꼬리를 이렇게 세우고 있네? 나를 좋아하나 보다 하면 이렇게 다가갔다가 물리시거나 이런 경우는 있는 거죠.
교회에도 이제 강아지 관련 상식들이 여러 가지가 있는데 논문으로 밝혀진.
저는 이것들을 진짜 인스타에서 너무 많이 봐가지고.
사람의 방귀 냄새가 반려견의 신경쇠약에 영향을 준다는.
악영향을 준다는 뜻인가요?
진짜 악영향을 주셔가지고 진짜로 이제 방귀도 끼지 말라는 거예요.
아주 개팔자가.
덜 받는 건 뭔지 아세요?
이 친구는 저 얼굴에 대고 껴요.
그러니까요. 상습범이에요.
그니까 바로 얼굴에다가 대고 껴요. 거의 일부러 그런다고 봐야 되거든요.
꼬리는 끼지 말라고 하는 게.
근데 이거 진짜 사실이네요 혹시?
근데 저는 사실 이거 정말 처음 들어보고.
어떤 로몬인지 좀 궁금하기는 해요.
그러니까 이거 좀 출처가 이상한데.
이거는 좀 진짜 저도 말이 안 된다고 생각하는데
근데 이거를 굳이 끼워 맞추자면
얘네들의 그 후각 능력은 사람보다 몇 백 배가 더 발달이 돼 있잖아요.
그러니까 같은 냄새라도
얘네는 좀 더
좀 더 좀 불쾌하게?
네, 독하게 느낄 수 있으니까
그것 때문에 얘네가 스트레스를 받는 거를 좀 이렇게 극단적으로 표현하지 않았나.
근데 강아지가 무슨 냄새건 좀
진한 냄새는 싫어한다고 알고 있거든요.
맞아요. 향수 냄새, 인공향 냄새는 좀 많이 독하게 받아들여요.
그러니까 방귀냄새로 악영향을 끼친다라는 논문이
저는 있을 수도 있다고 생각하는데
저는 그 논문을 쓴 사람이 일단 정신 상태가
좀 궁금합니다.
아마도 영국이었을 것 같아요.
아, 그리고 저거.
저거 저도 좀 궁금했어요.
반려견이 꿈을 꾸고 그 꿈에서도 보호자와 노는 경우가 많다고 함.
네, 이거 맞아요.
어떻게 알 수가 있어요?
저, 어, 자, 한마디만 말씀드리면
훌륭이는 꿈을 꿀 때 이상한 행동을 하거든요.
그 얼굴이
아, 이거 어떻게 설명, 이거 동영상을 보여드리면 제가 나중에 한번 찾아서 한번 보여드릴게요.
이 얼굴에 있는 모든 근육 있죠?
그게 다 따라 움직이거든요.
아주 기괴합니다, 그게.
이러면서 얼굴이 이쪽 눈 움직였다가 이쪽 눈 움직였다가 뭐.
그러니까 진짜 호러 영화 그 자체예요, 이걸 보고 있으면.
진짜 무섭거든요, 그거.
그 짓거리를 해요.
근데 아마도 꿈을 꾸는 건 것 같거든요.
네, 맞아요.
근데 그게 꿈인데, 그럼 도대체 무슨 꿈이죠?
아, 그게 아이들이 보통 그렇게 내무수면 상태일 때 이렇게 시룩시룩하고 눈도 막 왔다 갔다 하고 하거든요.
근데 그때 보통 꿈을 꿈대요.
그래서 사실 잠꼬대가 맞긴 하고.
강아지들이 되게 재밌는 게 사람은 꿈을 내가 현실에서 겪어보지 못했던 걸 꾸기도 하잖아요.
뭐 요즘 우주를 갔다 오거나 이러는데 강아지들은 자기가 겪은 것만 꿔요.
경험을 해본 것만.
그러니까 예를 들면, 그날 되게 신나게 잔디밭을 뛰어놀고 너무 재밌게 놀았다면 그런 것 중에 하나가 꿈에 나오는 거야.
자, 다음으로 사람과 비슷한 표정으로 눈썹을 내밀고 미소를 짓는 듯한 표정.
아, 강아지가 근데 웃상인 강아지들이 있어요, 그 종류에 따라서.
그래서 강아지도 웃고 울 수 있다라고 얘기를 하더라고요.
근데 맞나요?
네.
확실히 웃을 수는 있어요.
근데 슬퍼서 울지는 않아요.
슬픔이 없나요, 강아지는?
아니요, 슬픔이 있지만 그게 눈물로 이어지지는 않거든요.
그렇죠.
근데 웃을 때는 확실히 웃어요.
깜딩이는 분명히 우울한 표정이 있거든요.
지금 그 디폴트로 좀 표정이.
디폴트로 약간 이.
약간 울상이라고 해야 되나?
사색가.
시를 쓰는 표정인데, 우선.
시인 느낌이 있어요.
네.
근데 이거는 안 우울한 거고 정말 우울할 때 표정이 있습니다.
제가 이제 뭐 어디 해외 같은데 뭐 몇 방 며칠 갔다 오면은 그때 이제 집에 있는 사람이 사진 찍어 보면 우울해 보여요.
근데 이거는 보호자 정도만 알 수 있는 거 같아요.
맞아요.
네.
그리고 스트레스로 냄새를 감지한다고 하는데 이것도 사실인가요?
네. 그래서.
냄새로 감지하는 거예요?
네.
그 사람한테 어쨌든 스트레스 받으면 코르티솔 호르몬이 나오잖아요.
그 호르몬 냄새를 맡을 수 있어요.
오.
저 같은 경우는 이제 집에 같이 사니까 가벼운 말싸움 같은 거 할 때라든가.
큰 싸움도 아니에요.
살짝의 어떤 논쟁?
아주 가벼운?
그런 거 할 때 꼭 가운데에 와 있거든요, 제가.
그렇죠.
무조건 가운데에 와요.
그래서 서로를 쳐다봐요.
당장 멈추라는 듯이.
그거 어떤 중재 액션인가요?
모르겠어요. 그냥.
얘는 그 호르몬 냄새를 맡았으니까 이상한 기운을 느낀 거죠.
근데 이유는 몰라요.
아마 이유는 모를 거고.
왜 둘 다 이상하지?
기분이 이상한 거 같은데?
하고 이제 한번 와보는 거죠.
그러니까 뭔가를 좀 이렇게 깊게 의논을 하는 자리거나.
항상 그럴 때마다 이상한 분위기를 감지하고 와서 계속 서로한테 비벼요.
뭐냐?
그만해라.
뭐 이런 식으로.
그럼 그렇게 하면 그 이후에 어떻게 해주세요?
막 그냥.
그럼 이렇게 좀 쓰다듬고 좀.
네.
왜 prefix?
왜 이렇게 결국 정annya 하나 떨어질까?
중에 제가 여기에 나오게 된 건 네 번째인 것 같아요.
네.
아, 감사합니다.
기사 있잖아요. 나도 몰랐던 내 몸에 어떤 암과 무슨 종양을 강아지가 발견한다.
냄새로. 네. 그것도 맞아요. 그것도 연구 결과 있어요. 아 그러면 그거 어떻게. 암을 모를. 암인 건 모르지만 예를 들면 아이들이 평상시에
보호자님한테 느꼈던 냄새들이 있잖아요. 근데 예를 들면 악성암이나 이런게 생기면
약간 안에서 안좋은 그 호르몬들이 나오겠죠. 그러면 얘가 평상시에 느꼈던 보호자 냄새랑 다른거에요.
그리고 얘도 이상함을 느끼니까 자꾸 안좋은 쪽을 핥거나 아니면 더 붙어 있으려고 하거나 없던 분리불안이 생기거나
그래서 나중에 검사를 해봤더니 몸에 문제가 생기는 경우가 많은 거죠. 꼭 그게 암이 아니고 관절이 안좋다거나 몸의 한 부분이 안좋아도 아이들은 그걸 느끼는 경우가 있어요.
그럴 수 있겠네요. 그 강아지가
사람이 주는
강아지의
간식 개수를 알 수 있다고 하더라고요.
그건 좀 이제 건방지네요. 그런 것까지 센다는 거는 주는 대로 먹을 것이지.
그러니까 근데 저는 한 네 다섯 개 이후로 못 셀 것 같다는 생각은 있긴 한데.
맞아요. 그래서 이거를 이게 약간 좀 너무 깊이 들어간 게 많이 주는지 적게 주는지는 알아요.
그래서 저희는 어떻게 해야 되냐면 얘네가 되게 웃긴 게 큰 거 이만큼 하나 주는 거랑 조그마한 거 하나 주는 걸 어쨌든 얘네한테는
똑같이 받은 거예요. 그래서 차라리 이거 하나를 10개로 쪼개면 이거 하나 주는 것보다 10번 준다고 생각을 하는 거죠.
멍청한 녀석들.
결국에 먹은 건 이만한 건 똑같은 건데 이거 하나는 하나라고 생각을 하고 이렇게 나눠서 주면 나 되게 많이 얻어 먹었다 라고 생각을 해요.
그럼 무조건 작은 거를 좀 많이 주는 게 더 좋아요.
네. 그럼 얘 입장에서는 오늘 되게 많이 먹었다 라고 생각하는데 실제로 이거 하나.
기분이 너무 좋아가지고.
이거 뭡니까? 유명한 강아지 짤.
와 이 밑에 짤은 많이 봤어요.
사람이 죽으면 먼저 가 있던 반려동물이 마중 나오는 인기가 있다. 이거.
저건 이제 유명한 어떤 템플릿이 됐죠.
그렇죠.
네. 뭐만 하면 다 갖다 붙일 수 있는 말이 됐고.
근데 좀 믿고 싶은 얘기인 것 같긴 해요. 저건.
저도. 근데 저는 일부러 좀 저런 어떤 반려견의 죽음 같은 콘텐츠를 안 봅니다.
저는 얘기도 하지 않아요.
네.
저는 생각조차 없고.
네. 자꾸 뭐 그런 얘기하면 이제 나중에 화나요.
그래서 오히려 사람이 죽는 콘텐츠를 더 많이 보죠.
그런 건 즐거워요.
즐겁죠. 죽이고 죽고 죽는.
누가 뭐 잔인하게 죽는다.
그런 게 좋고.
훌륭한 영화군요.
반려견은 못 보겠다.
강아지 죽는 건 좀 안 보고 싶어요.
네.
MZ당아지요?
얘네가요?
생각해보면 그 풍산개라는 밴드가 있었던 것 같아요.
되게 근본 있는 아드락 밴드.
야 이렇게 막 어중이떠중이 모였으니까 우리 그냥 삽살개다.
네.
포메라니아.
항상 똑똑한 척은 하지만 싸가지가 없습니다.
일단 도베르만이 저는 색깔이 좀 더 많은 것 같아요.
약간 더 인터넷 같은 느낌이 나거든요.
악동뮤니션.
도베르만이?
도베르만으로 가겠습니다.
무슨.
아 축하드립니다.
와.
오늘 그래서 이제 우리가 서로 각자 강아지의 마음을 좀 다 잘 이해하게 됐을까요?
글쎄요.
뭐 저들이 어떤 생각을 하고 사는지 일단 별 생각 안 할 것 같긴 한데
뭐 그거는 백프로 알 수는 없겠죠 우리가 이런 걸.
백프로 우리가 파악을 할 수는 없겠지만 그래도 좀 더 그런 부분에 대해서
개인적으로 궁금했던 것들을 알려주셔서 저는 좀 많이 도움이 되고 좋았습니다.
아주 흥미로웠습니다 저는.
저도 너무너무 도움이 많이 됐고
제가 그래도 어 깜딩이를 그래도 좀 괜찮게 키우고 있구나라는 어떤 생각도 들었어요.
네.
그런데 저는 되게 깜짝 놀란 게 정말 제가 막 피드백 드릴만한 게 없어요.
너무 잘해주고.
워낙 훈련을 키우고 있으니 굳이 한 말이 있을까 싶기도 하죠.
워낙 저희가 또.
완벽하지 않습니까 이런.
우리가 진짜 좋은 반려인입니다.
민경님 혹시 저희에게 궁금한 거 있으신가요.
잠시만요.
아 강진이 님께 깜딩이란.
네.
아 깜딩이.
내 인스타 도우미.
내 조회수 도우미? 내 좋아요 도우미?
근데 저는 그런 건 있습니다
깜딩이 때문에 더 강해지는 게 있는 거 같아요
다 필요 없고 얘만 있으면 됩니다
그럴 수 있죠
내가 오늘 잘 안 풀려도
잘 풀려도 난 얘만 있으면 된다
깜딩이랑 있는데 내가 무서울 게 뭐가 있냐
이런 느낌이 있어요
그 정도까지
새건데요
허킹, 홀룡이랑
홀룡이는 저의 가족이고
가장 친한 친구가 아닐까
항상 일단은 같이 옆에서 자고
일어날 때 같이 일어나고
우리가 대화를 나누고 이러진 않지만
여자친구가 스트레스를 냄새로 맡듯이
그런 것들이 이미 어떤
나의
생활과 나의 어떤 기분과
이런 것들을 항상 공유하는 기분이 들어서
이런 존재가 있다는 거가
저는 굉장히 하루하루 맨날 감사해요
볼 때마다
정말 감사하고
하여튼 그런 어떤
그래도 그런 자세한 부분에 대해서
수의사님이 또 잘 설명을 해 주셔가지고
제가 많이 도움이 됐습니다
감사합니다
하여튼 비주류 초대석 오늘은 또
최민경 수의사님
깜딩이 그리고 홀룡이는
누군지 모르겠지만 하여튼!
이렇게 여러 인물들과 함께 얘기를 해 보았는데요
오늘 저희의 반려견 데뷔 프로젝트
반려견을 이용한
스윗 발견함
이미지 탈피 프로젝트
이미지 변신 방송에
반려견을 이용한
근데 저도 지금 놀랐어요
놀라셨죠
진짜 스윗 반려인이신 것 같아가지고
응
아이고
저희는
다음에 또 어떻게 만나게 될지
모르겠지만
저희 어떻게 만나게 될까요?
저희는 또 뭘 시키게 될지
머니그라피 피디님께서
다음에 또 어떤 걸 시킬지 저한테
모르겠지만
한번 또
기대를 해보도록 해봅시다
감사합니다
안녕
수고하셨습니다
고생하셨습니다